you
i'm john burgess a designer on the sims
4 and i want to give you a look at our
new build mode in the sims 4 i can
create homes with more detail and more
personality than ever building is faster
and easier in an earlier video we
created bella and Mortimer goth now
let's create their home in the sims 4 I
can create my ideal floor plan by
drawing walls or simply placing down
rooms and pushing and pulling them into
shape to make this even faster I can
place fully furnished style grooms to
suit the gas traditional tastes I'm
going to choose rooms from the Queen
Anne style as I resize rooms the game
will intelligently adjust the placement
of furniture and walls you can see just
how quick it is to create homes in the
sims 4 because Mortimer's of bookworm
and a genius I want to give him a study
to fit his refined tastes and for the
outgoing Bella I've built a dining room
she'd be proud to host a soiree
in the sims 4 walls can be set to three
different heights windows can be added
to a room with just one click and I can
adjust their placement along the wall I
can add new architectural details with
just a few clicks I push and pull a roof
into the shape I want and I'll finish it
off with some shrimp now I can add a
foundation and change its height at any
time I'm almost done but I want to add
some finishing touches some plants and
I'll paint the terrain here there this
house looks great now I want to give you
a peek as some other spots around the
neighborhood this home is a perfect and
affordable place for a group of
roommates just starting out and write an
entire building can even be moved at
once now this looks like a great spot
for a wedding and there's plenty of room
in this modern home for a
multi-generational family let's check
back in on bella and Mortimer everyone's
loving their new place I can't wait to
see the houses you'll be creating thanks
for watching
you